Databricks is taking over the world of data engineering. Back 5-10 years ago there were
so many other technologies, now it seems like Databricks is going to be king. So we should be
learning it. We should be learning it quickly and powerfully and it has these new AI features that
we also need to be learning. So the average Databricks engineer makes like 150-200k and
through my five-week program I can help you get there as well. And we teach you everything that
you need to know from the fundamental data sets with Delta Lake and how to create very powerful
compact data sets as well as how to build scalable etl with apache spark at the end of this bootcamp
you will be able to do big pipelines fast pipelines all the different types of pipelines
that you need to also then feed into ai because now databricks also offers agent bricks agent
bricks is another ai agent platform that we will also be covering in this five week program this
five week program honors your time it is scheduled for the evenings so if you're a working professional
It's six to eight Pacific time.
And if you can't make any class,
the recording is available right after.
So know that like we are structured
for working professionals as well as students.
It's for everybody.
So if you wanna join today
and really take your Databricks career seriously,
check the link below.